[Applause]
thank you too much Alton Jordan
Esperanto yeah I just wanted to quickly
say that following all the Jeffries talk
we will have a question answer period so
five minutes from now we'll have people
walking by the aisles taking your
question sheets as well as on the
balcony so on and after college every
class will have a question answer period
and if you have more questions after
that both white roses well just pass
them up and if you're on the balcony
just give them to Aiden thank you very
much in college every good evening well
the Ted and I have had a and a running
debate over the last few weeks is what
would be worth doing first or the wing
lap how do I follow that the second
century church is rather strange and
point astonishing stories about Jesus
which has been circulating orally for
some generation began to be written down
in the second half of the first century
when numerous versions in circulation
which came over time to be associated
with the traditions of one or another
Apostolic witness to the risen Lord
chief and a certain point a choice had
to be made the church could have come up
with a definitive account the single
canonical version their approach was
certainly a temptation one of the first
to do this was a dualistic heretic
called Marshall he said it on one gospel
the Gospel of Luke will happen like that
one can she read a clear color to suit
his vision his identity also rejected
the entirely testament in the process
teaching that matter was evil and
therefore the creators are the field has
was responsible for a whole but the
point here is that he wanted a single
gospel to reflect Jesus who Esau is
offering salvation from this material
world how the hell the single this idea
of a single golf is continuing to be a
temptation even for those within the
canonical Church in the middle of the
second century and otherwise quite
Orthodox believers patience apparently
standardized by the plurality of
developers created a famous be
accessible in this world the Gospel
accounts with one painless consistent
narrative and it had contraction in fact
for some century particularly among the
theory a tradition this was the main
goal for youth but the church rejected
both of any attempt and from the
beginning of the process of the
canonization of the New Testament it
accepted that there should be different
scopes
leading the charge was the 2nd century
bishop of meal Irenaeus who insisted or
what he called the as an galleons tetra
mortal the four four Gospels already in
his day day those were the four golf as
we have in our New Testament today this
is important only aware of the
significant differences in the account
not only different emphases theological
vision a contradiction the church chose
to canonize diversity it chose to retain
four separate and distinctive literary
compositions witnessing to the life
death and resurrection of Jesus this is
interesting for all kinds of reasons and
of course it points to the experience of
Jesus being more profound than any one
account to capture but not least and for
our purposes and pain tonight it also
says something about the meaning of what
it is to be human as you Jacqueline
scholar weeks
Timothy Johnston life the diversity of
the Gospel accounts
signifying the infinite records metric
of ability of the storing of Jesus in
the life of human being
of Jesus is not simply the past the
church declare but continues of the
spirit of Jesus transformed the life of
human beings according to the mind of
Christ but in what sense can the story
of Jesus directly surely not in the
specifics of his ministry which are
irretrievably in the past not about
being a celibate bearded Jewish male
rollin up in Galilee in the first
century Palestine of Technol someone who
works at a time like his foster father
such historical elements are not
repeatable neither are they important to
the peace rather the plurality of the
gospel in their variety of and
contradictory historical details and
beyond all this to a deeper significance
that is to the meaning of the story of
Jesus contained in his hands it's not a
fact for Jesus's life that naturally
find new expression in your lives of
others but rather the pattern of
hypocrisy Jesus existence is one of
radical obedience towards God and
selfless service to what others formed a
pattern for all humanity that can be
written in the heart by the Holy Spirit
if this pattern that Paul designates as
a normal to see often translated a law
of Christ but as better understood
perhaps as The Passion of Christ the
patterns of the Messiah as an aside this
concept of the pattern of Christ
acting to the multiform narrative that
witness to the life death and
resurrection of Jesus was also the
reason for the limits that were placed
on what could be considered gospel you
see a diversity was not just allowed
that a requirement to express the
fullness of truth there was never left a
bridge to follow and the rejection of
the so-called Gnostic self realization
I'm sure many of you are familiar with
precisely that they were not analysis
but often just collections of Saints and
that makes sense
the Gnostics you're not interested in
the material
world and how the story requires
materiality their sacred text much as
much as they purported to be about Jesus
lacks precisely the narrative elements
of the patterning of Christ
the time does not suffice for us to
explore together to teach me how across
all the various writings of the New
Testament his underlying Passion of
Christ emerges permit me to outline the
very brief detection in the four Gospels
in the letters of Paul and other early
apostles behind all the collective
factors there's a deep consistency in
the earliest Christian literature
concerning a focus not on wondrous deeds
or even wise words but on the character
of Jesus of Messiah on the meaning of
his life and death
a overview the same Cochrane of radical
obedience to God and selfless love
towards other people they reveal a
journey it's lungers to the depth of
alienation in solidarity with all and
then rises in glorification having not
merely overcome suffering sin and death
but emptiness of their power a reveal a
pattern of joyful sacrifice
voluntary death and glorious
resurrection and they also all agree on
this that destroyers ship is to follow
the same messianic passions they don't
emphasize the followers of Jesus
performed certain deeds or learn certain
doctrines they insist rather or living
according to the same pattern of life
and death showing by Jesus via
Christians effort is one of those dull
knives with immorality
although there are dogmatic and ethical
implications it's not about all that
religious baggage we so often associated
it is to live it is for each of us to
enact in our unique human existence the
normal system of conscience right now
there are numerous ways we can describe
this pattern applies for instance the
eastern or other principal motive xyg
understanding scriptures typology we can
add to pattern who were talking in other
words people or type a type is a person
an object or an event that is connected
across space-time to others without
losing its own historical reality and
identity it shares in a greater reality
of meaning that greater reality which at
Point a greater reality called the
antigen this is how the Apostles and the
Church Fathers read the entire Old
Testament for example Adam st. Paul says
is it people a type of Christ the first
created man pointing forward to the
recreation of the human life rate who
Christ Jesus the exodus narrative as an
event is a type of the true Passover or
cosmic christ deliverance of all people
from suffering and death and anyone is
familiar with the writings of the church
fathers or the Liturgy of your thoughts
church who know how abundant Heights are
within them but this is the key
technology is not just a way of reading
another standing history and tech seeing
how people and events point toward
Christ the psychology is for Easterns
father the fundamental structure of
reality of a world that is involved of
an epiphany or theophany of God and of
our own apprehension of this reality our
own findings of meaning within so it's
not just figure from scriptural history
that are typed we too are called to
tipis on front to be symbols of Christ
participants in his archetypal journey
and life his descent wietfeldt offerings
and his offense in glory if we are to be
truly human we must follow what
distinguished scholar of this university
Northrop Frye calls the u-shaped story
it is a foundation not only a biblical
narrative and the Christ course but a
story after story miss after me in
Christ the archetype of archetypes
we have in the words of CS Lewis miss
become fast as we've already heard this
evening when the Gospel of st. John of
course this pattern is above all called
global not an abstract pattern but to
direct in these latter days in the
fullness of time a direct incarnate
expression of God Himself the logos is
the principle of order and creation as
we heard it through the logos the God
speaks and all things are made it is
logo God verb that's better than words
verbs in whose image we are created
whose life has we are called to attain
and the lesson here is simply that a
properly ordered human life is one lived
in accordance with the local the concept
of logos has a long and venerable
history and it did even before the
Greece translators of the Old Testament
and the New Testament writers
appropriated it and one of the first or
the first of a Greek philosophers the
speak of logos was the pre-socratics
Heraclitus and he said this Hulagu the
aerbook knows augustine equally although
logos is common to all all have the
logos the many lives as if they had a
wisdom their own in other words global
may govern the universe the macro cosmos
and our own inner world the meat were
both walls but most people don't choose
a properly ordered life or life
aligned with the compass built into the
fabric of the world built into their own
heart and mind we've heard already we
are now in the season of great length
the great fortune day and it has many
significance is refusing the course of
ascetic labor of renewal of faith
redoubling of our commitment to prayer
and the service of others so for the
season of preparing catechumen the
baptism of love over its the season will
recall to come to our sense and to awake
to the fundamental meaning
and pattern of our life we realize our
alienation we repent with Hanlon we
embark on our journey of return a
journey which involves self-sacrifice a
journey in which necessarily passes
through our involuntary death and
resurrection when he's an action the
totality of our life but it requires to
remembrance death it was a famous
practice in ancient Rome as a general
came back victorious from a backward and
during his triumphant parade we received
compliments and honors from the crowd of
citizens
he ran the risk of falling victim to his
own crime and delusions of grandeur and
to avoid that a slave would be placed up
behind him you spring into his ear
saying hey pasta pay only em que momento
look after you
she's kind of your death and remember
you're only a man thereafter he was
enshrined and picked up in Christian
tradition a memento mori remember that
you will die but then again remember to
die remember to just might think we need
that remember it but see because
eventually all of us would probably fool
people to the curb but remember to die
because remember to find and follow the
logo the pattern of our true life which
passes through gets to resurrection very
frequent theme and patristic physicians
in Gregory the theologian often repeats
the saying of Plato who suggests that
the present life ought to be a
meditation upon death and he advised to
friend to ligurius to live instead of a
present of future and they fit like a
meditation and practice of death to go
on from the Church Fathers some focus on
death in its front-and-center
remembrance of our journey the passage
from death to life
this is also the connection of length
with the preparation for baptism baptism
in deepest and coronary sense
signifies death and burial and
resurrection
this is very clear in Romans chapter 6
the Epistle which revealed on the eve of
Easter pasta
we have been baptized into Christ desc
we have been buried with him by baptism
into death we have been United to Christ
in a deathlike age and United to him in
a resurrection rightful baptism in death
and resurrection came gregory of nyssa
PES performed is both tomb and mother
nor thought of theologian paul and so he
knows right about this scene an extended
vacation is their business
dr. Bini says means sharing mystically
in Christ's death and his burial but
also in what happened between his burial
and his resurrection his descent into
hell what is the meaning of the
Incarnation God becoming truly human and
Christ identifies himself with all human
anguish alienation and despair in the
Garden of Gethsemane he says my soul is
exceedingly sorrow even unto death he
shares in the fullness of human pain he
entered into the fullness not only of
human life but of human death and we are
to understand Christ descent into hell
as being the full expression of God's
solidarity with our human alienation
Christ descends into the hell of human
suffering and a human lowly loneliness
and human despair surely he has borne
our griefs and carried our sorrows as we
read in the book of Isaiah and we may
add the price conform all our groups all
our souls there is a total
identification here an unreserved
solidarity of Christ our God in our
human Parliament he who is sinless yet
became sin for us became one with us in
our fallen state as impulses and that is
part of the meaning of this descent into
hell all things
aussolas off he's intense so I go down
to hell thou art there also we need from
138 so when we are baptized as the
kilo continues we descended price into
health we also commit ourselves in
solidarity replies to the same total
unreserved identification with those who
suffer each of the baptized becomes by
virtue of its descent into hell with
Christ a man or a woman for others each
of us is called to bear the grief of
others and to carry their third via
Christian name to be a human requires us
to journey to hell it is in no two
journey to hell and become hell
for himself that's how we can make sense
of the words of a great elder of the
20th century thankful for me who went a
month asking how will we be saved
answered keep your mind in hell and
despair no white house why the archetype
in defense before ascending why did you
happen across that we must follow then
I'm a curve of physics if you indulge me
let me offer a medicine into this and I
boringest from a scholar of Orthodox
Christian liturgy gave this case a giver
Archimedes was a rich physicist who is
fascinated by the mechanic mathematics
of believers and you may remember from
your science classes in simple machines
for the leaders used to exert a large
force over a small distance by exerting
a small force over a greater distance at
the other end a child cannot lift with
one hand a man standing on the short end
of the beam if the child presses down on
the long Archimedes was so fast amoeba
the leaders potential that one day he
famously explains
give me a lever and a place to stand and
I shall move and he realized he did
three things in order to move you along
enough leaver
a correctly placed spoke from points and
a place to stand but that of course was
the problem when it comes to moving here
how could he apply leverage to the world
when he himself was standing on the
little healthy
possibly he lives on in order to move it
he has a footed so in philosophy the
riddle becomes known as searching for
the Archimedean point that is an
objective standpoint remove from the
object of study his hypothetical point
of perspective is thought to be far
enough removed from something in order
to extort an outsider's viewers but how
can we remove ourselves to a point
outside of them this is our human
condition Agustin defines sin as people
raucous insane mean currently upon
oneself a life oriented inwardly toward
self rather than outwards towards awe
and others our ego centrism exerts so
strong a gravitational pull that extends
the right of glory back on ourselves
that light that should be glorifying God
how can we move ourselves off-center we
are the center of our universe we have
no leverage over things we have no
standpoint our pride our vanity and
pride we have no rock on which to stand
that is beyond our self-interest whoever
desires to get outside himself with some
sort of Archimedean point beyond himself
our self offering and our descent to
have is precisely this Archimedean form
is not so religious if we are to
transform the world into our true symbol
and epiphany of God's own life and we
was first he said we cannot lift up the
world in sacrificial praise so long as
we place our footing on the world alone
it is like trying to lift the carpeting
while we stand on it Archimedes problem
was applying leverage to a world that he
could not step off of in order to music
but we can by dying with Christ we are
free in the world
we leave the world for the sake of the
world we die for the knees in the world
with a mist this is not merely our
spiritual life our religious locations
some crazy notion brings up by men in
black dresses
it is our true life these are proper
life it is our life order according to
the robot and it is a journey we must
undertake the undertake not on our own
but only in Christ for Christ and Christ
alone the one who took that journey so
that we could be reconciled to go in
closing I would like to turn to one of
the greatest in my own estimation poets
of the past century one who saw
thankfully into these realities of
locals a journey through death and
resurrection we had poem The Waste Land
TF Elliot depicts our Beach with fair
isle world it's a world in which we fail
to take up our journey where we stay put
amidst the civilization that's been
reduced to a wasteland that has lost its
fertility and its ability to bring forth
life the world is filled he says with a
heap of broken images and the dead trees
gives no shelter there is no easy fix
and certainly nothing in that
civilization or society could offer
there's no leverage the such a world is
dominated today you need to look at
Eliot's final work before cortex for
hopes of renewal and spiritual
replenishing tellingly above this series
of four hosts the last eighty votes
he's inscribed those words of Heraclitus
that I mentioned before
overall though his common the many live
as if they had wisdom of their own area
tested the solution to our wasteland is
not renewed civilization per se on its
own terms but a journey undertaken in
the passion of the local he says this is
a single perspective yes all shall be
well and all manner of things shall be
well by the purification of the motives
in the ground of our big future it goes
on to evoke and image this beautiful
image of the fire the holy spirit
purifying
duh terrifying the world of his descent
as ago he ended with it in a hopefully
in which descent today is the source of
life and meaning and transformation we
die with desire
see they depart and we go with them we
are born with the dead they return and
bring us with the moment of a rose and
the moment of the you tree are of equal
duration of people without history is
not redeemed sometime for history is a
pattern of timeless moments so while the
light bear on a winter's afternoon in a
secluded Chapel history is now in the
drawing of this love and the voice of
this column we shall not cease from
exploration and the end of all our
exploring will be to arrive where we
started and know the place for the first
part through the unknown remembers gate
when the last of the earth left to
discover is that which was the vision at
the source of the longest river the
voice of the hidden water hole and the
children and the apple trees not know
because not looks for but her happens in
the stillness between two waves of the
sea yes
now always a condition to complete
simplicity costing not less than every
and all shall be well and all manner of
thing shall arise when the tongues of
flame are in folded and the grounded
water fire and the fire rope
[Applause]